I've always been very positive about the
new India
I've been saddened by the fact that
after several years of very progressive
growth there's been a stumbling activity
that has been a country driven by
accusations of corruption not wrong akia
rightly so crony capitalism and a
government that has withdrawn its pace
of growth right at the same time I feel
that that has been that is bottomed out
and we're on a path again to grow but
we've got to rebuild we've gone from an
eight eight percent plus growth rate
down to sub five briefly right yeah we
will grow back to the growth rate we had
we will need to control inflation but I
think India will once again the same
spirit of the people will make it make
it happen